hey everyone welcome to live coding with
Jessie I'm Jessie and in this stream you
all get to see me do my work as a
front-end developer and I don't plan
this ahead of time so I make a lot of
mistakes when we work through the
mistakes together this is very much an
interactive stream so I'm gonna paste
the link into the live chat now if you
go to that link you'll be able to see
the project as we work on it if I update
it on my computer locally you will see
the updates in real time you can inspect
the site with dev tools you can go on
different pages so you're not limited at
what I'm showing you on my screen and we
split everything up into Pomodoro
sessions so if you're not familiar with
the Pomodoro Technique I definitely
recommend it but basically that we were
using it on this dream is that for 25
minutes we do some code and I have
minimal interaction with the live chat
then for five minutes I go to the live
chat and I focus on all of your
questions and comments then we do
another 25-minute session of code and
then at the end of that I go through all
the remaining comments and questions so
feel free to add your questions in and
if you see me doing something wrong
you're just not sure why I'm doing
something a certain way put that in a
live chat as well I get a lot of great
advice from all of you in the chat and
really the projects are much better off
because of that so I welcome your your
input if you want to check out the
github repo the link is in the
description to this video everyone this
is also a little earlier than normal let
me know what you think about this
earlier time does it work better for you
all you know I I know that I can't I
can't stream and at a time that'll work
for everyone's schedule but sometimes
it's good to switch up the time and just
see who can make it and who can't so let
me know about that
today let me switch my camera there we
are
so today we're gonna work on the search
filters that we started to work on last
week at some point and we're gonna try
to actually get them working so I'm not
sure what I did to the search but it
doesn't work for me at all now
so evidently we left it in a broken
state which is okay we'll figure that
out now let me check we have some
activity in the live chat let's check
this before we start our timer the other
question is this all on code pen no this
isn't on cope and the code isn't is in
github and you can use that link let me
post the link again in case you weren't
in in the chat yet so the link that I
just posted in the live chat will let
you view the site as we're working on it
sometime very soon this test version of
the site will be available 24/7 so when
that happens you all will have the link
for the test version of the site alright
hey everyone
alright so I do want to let you all know
that this site is gonna launch soon so
we need to get it ready so on the
streams we'll be working on things like
a search and we'll be working on the
routing and some like minor UI
improvements for me when I'm not doing a
live stream I'm gonna be working on
getting all the remaining data
transferred over so it's gonna be
somewhat boring for me but I'm gonna try
to keep the actual streams a little bit
more exciting let's see I'm also
considering using now instead of making
multiple servers on digitalocean so if
anybody has any experience
using now especially for projects like
this please let me know what your
opinion on that is I I haven't tested it
yet I'd like to test it first and maybe
read up a little more on it but it seems
like it's gonna be a better solution in
that there'll be less things to maintain
and it'll be it'll scale automatically
much more easily then if we've actually
had to go in start up new digitalocean
servers or take them down okay so let's
go to the search page on this site oops
almost forgot to start the timer where
is my timer there it is
let's pull the timer over on our screen
here so you don't have to switch
everything around all right so we're
gonna start this Pomodoro time and this
timer happened to be built by Harsha
who is frequently in the live streams
and has contributed a lot to our github
repos all right so let's go to that
search page if you have the end rock
link you can check out the search page
as well so right now if I try to do a
search I'm getting the black screen with
an error so I'm not going to even try it
right now but what we are gonna do and I
don't need this would be quite so large
we're going to get these working so that
will make a search with these check box
boxes whether they're going to be
checked in or not and it will alter the
results that we get back for our search
so here's our search component I'm gonna
make a little bit of room here and then
increase the text size so let's shrink
that down and to move this over we can
also move this side over a bit and I
think that should be big enough let me
know if it's hard for any of you to see
but
you know if you're on at least a desktop
you know with decent resolution this
should work I'm not really sure how it
will look on a phone let's see so here's
our filter so we have this some
functions already in here we have a few
functions that we're not actually using
yet that we brought over from a previous
project so let's take second and sort
things out just to see where we are
since it has been about a week since we
worked on this all right so here's these
are just our Styles we can skip through
the Styles here in our state let's take
a look at what we have going on so we
this is for the data when it does come
back from the wordpress api which is
where we're going to get the data from
this is gonna house our search term this
is going to house the type of search we
want to do so in this case it's going to
be the post types that we'd like to
search for so that's where our filters
come into play all of our check boxes
are also our filters so these are the
values true or false check they're not
checked here's what we actually make the
API calls so this base is going to be
the same always and this URL for now
this is going to be this IP address will
be the URL but that may change in fact
it's likely to change when we get closer
to launch but for this we take the
search term which is what's typed into
the input and then we add the search
type or multiple types which is what
we'll get from the check box and then
that whole string gets sent to the
WordPress API all right so the the logic
for that lives in another component so
I'm not going to go over that right now
but if you check out the the fetch
component we
we call it yeah so in the in the utils
folder the component named fetch is
that'll show you what's going on there
if you want to check it out in the
github repo all right so we have some
logic for getting the value out of that
checkbox
we're debouncing so that we don't fire
off a bunch of API calls you know more
than we need and let's see I'm gonna get
search results I'd like to see where our
problem is you know what let's run a
search and see what that error message
looks like I know we got results with
that search term since this website for
a Catholic school so they're gonna have
that word in there somewhere all right
so our data there is no data really this
state data map is not a function so
we're trying to map over data but there
there's no data let's check that out
let's see where we're doing that this
states map
this they data map okay so here's where
we're doing that so if this state data
hmm I thought we'd taken care of this I
guess not
let's shut that leg is greater than zero
oops let's try a check like that I mean
I still think it might not even go
through this check but let's see let's
see how that works okay so we're not
getting an error anymore which is good
let's see what's happening in our in our
console what we're getting here
oh okay interesting type program is
required for a matter it needs to be an
array
okay so the problem seems to be with our
types
all right so let's see what we're doing
here
alright I'm gonna check the live chat as
well see if anyone's seeing anything
that I don't okay hey everybody I see a
lot of people saying hi that's all right
well let's step through this a little
bit more closely
hmm
look at my error again
type 4 Ram is a required parameter and
it needs to be an array
okay you know what maybe I'm just
formatting this in the wrong way
okay
this is the R is an example that they're
giving back of what it needs to be like
so it's only sending this so my I see
[Music]
you know we need to make we need to make
a checkbox that's for all so obviously
the default is going to be to search
everything right I think that's expected
users will expect that by default
everything is going to be searched and
then as you check things it'll narrow it
down so we need to send a string that
searches for every post type at first
now I'm not going to create that string
right now but at least in terms of the
filters that we're using we can search
for all of them then once a checkbox is
checked then we switch over and use what
we have from there so it'll be I think
the easiest way to fix this is to say
this is
I want to make sure that we're clearing
the search type first or it's at least
somewhere we're clearing it price filter
alright we're not using the price filter
yet filter by category we're not
actually using this yet
there we are
no worries and let's search string equal
okay all right this'll work
that'll work
all right so what we need then is to
have a default value for this search
type and we'll worry about how to get
back to the all a different time or
should the value oh how about this this
can be a little different than I thought
but what if the default value for the
check boxes is true that should solve
everything the default value for every
check box will be true and then users
can go through and uncheck things they
don't want I think it would be useful
maybe to have some option to just clear
all but I think that's going to be our
quickest solution right now so let's do
that and this should give us results
true and let's see when does that change
does it just change on click or are we
doing it on search as well
it sir saves
maybe we should move this let's move
this from when a checkbox is checked to
when we're actually gonna get results
get search results
the Divas assist
okay
I don't remember which which one of
these is actually being called let's go
down to our form we'll have to clean
that up at some point I don't think we
need that those examples anymore so we
can probably get rid of our input change
get search results is what gets called
all right so this is the one that gets
called debounce search okay what we
probably should do some of this I'm not
going to delete it right away
but at first we're gonna run that there
we are all right the reason that I want
to run this in the search is that we win
it when the component first mounts and
everything's checked it won't actually
add those terms to our search type
string until someone checks or uncheck
the check box but we want those added
right away so the alternative would have
been would have been to manually add
that search string which may still be a
better alternative but for right now I
think this will be quicker and allow us
to test our system and just make sure it
works and then we can handle refactoring
it and let's try this
could see against me penny Suresh
alright I'm gonna wait I just I was
gonna pull that down here but let's just
see if this works no it's just refresh
and let's check yeah it works alright
great now let's toggle this so I can
just see what's going on a little bit
easier okay so now if I click faculty I
should only get faculty okay I didn't
even get any faculty members on this
search oh you know what that should
trigger another search so let's make
we're going to make sure we we have a
trigger another search all right so that
that's not working properly
so let's see this is not checked we
searched but we could see it's still
searching for this old type so I've done
something incorrectly so I know two
things one we got to make sure we clear
out the old search term in state and add
the new one and then we also need it to
search automatically when we check
things so that's I think that's what
users expect I don't want to make users
have to manually click search again all
right so let's check it out rid of that
okay so let's see what happens when we
do check a check box we'll go down here
and start first with our check box so
when I check the faculty check box it
says this handle change and then faculty
so let's scroll up and look at handle
change so handle change takes the name
the event checked so this day check
boxes check boxes name equals checked
this state check boxes okay so we're
changing the state of that particular
check box good so this state check box
has changed now what needs to happen as
well is a search needs to happen there
so let's go up to see what our search
gets search results
so you know what we we can should we
skip this create search types yeah we're
not gonna be able to get the correct
event if we call this so we're not gonna
call that I wanna see what our create
search type yes
okay all right so I think we should call
this fetch search term it's gonna get
everything it needs from state anyway
and I guess we need we ought to move
this then
since when we're not see what we're
gonna run this
alright you know what let's let's have
it here and then let's also have it here
oops did we have here
let's have it here oh I lost what I had
copy
all right let's see if we've changed
anything here okay that works
no let's go faculty you know what I
didn't
I missed this that let's try to search
with that and now it didn't change
anything that's interesting so it should
have
hmm yeah it still didn't change anything
wait a second all right I see what's
happening the let's check on the state
because these should have been checked
by default I don't think we're using
controlled components here and that's I
mean that's one problem we need to solve
no matter what
here we go here's a state let's shrink
this a bit and I'm gonna increase the
size on dev tools you all can see what's
happening oh that's too big okay so our
state's here's our data search term
search type there we are
okay so let's refresh now check it out
again okay search term search type so
let's do it so here's our search type
our check boxes are all true and if I
check it it stays true
now it's full so I check once check
twice so now my search type is correct
so if I went like that see now it just
gives me majors so I can unclick that so
we just need to change that initial
state faculty great ok there we have the
faculty all right so hopefully that
makes sense that were at least part of
our problem was the check boxes weren't
showing that they were actually checks
it took two clicks to get anything to
change so when I come back from the
break we're gonna make sure we we fixed
that the check box is being checked
right off the bat and then I also do
want to automatically search again when
these check boxes are checked or
unchecked so let's take a break now and
I'm gonna scroll all the way up to the
top of the chat and just work my way
down and I do I'm expecting an email so
I keep checking my email
if you see me like bending down to look
that's that's what I'm looking at
so we have hello from Italy someone from
Spain hey how's it going thanks for
watching
so we have some opinions on the screen
time so the time was good for some not
so good for others so I'm gonna continue
to maybe stream like around noon
somewhere around there but I may need to
do other times
hmm excuse me sorry for the yawn when I
do that I always hope I don't make a lot
of other people yawn you know how
yawning is contagious
alright so on on yuge
it's a nuj please let me know how to
correctly pronounce that but on yuge
says hey buddy what you working on I'm
kind of new here but subscribe to you
long-long the way back alright awesome
well thank you for subscribing and
thanks for watching so basically we have
this rack project and we're trying to
make a search function within react so
we did get the search function working
but now we want to add in some filters
so you can see it's it's working but the
controls for the filters aren't very
good right now so we're gonna try to
work on those Michael says early starts
today yeah it wasn't early start today I
might go to lunch with some of my
coworkers so they've been asking me they
asked me to go to lunch frequently and I
usually stream during lunch so I've kind
of skipped out on a lot of stuff so I
think I want to I want to try to go
today and hang out with them a bit
I michael says what if we do search
filter equals search filter or the star
maybe yes you know it's something like
that something like that could work as
well
yeah maybe will that that may end up
being like the final solution that I use
I think that's a better solution than
what I'm doing now SIB la silla fat
sorry if I'm mispronouncing that please
let me know what I'd love to I'd love to
be able to pronounce that correctly but
anyway they say hi Jesse I did subscribe
you awesome thank you very much for
subscribing and I do have another
channel so that I stream on the free
code camp Channel and then I also do
some videos on my own channel not nearly
as many videos but I think I am going to
be start producing more like small very
focused tutorial videos so if you're
interested in that please subscribe to
my channel as well I think there's a
link to it in the description and
occasionally I do some live streams on
that channel as well usually I like live
streams about side projects and
tutorials that I'm working on hey Anna
how's it going thanks for joining us I'd
be nervous how long my Pomodoro sessions
are 25 minute sessions with five minute
break in between NS if I was sick I'm
not like fully sick I have a sore throat
and I was really congested all night but
I'm sorry it's starting to clear up now
so I hope I'm not getting sick thank you
for asking though Brian Sizemore who is
in the office right next to me said I
yawn said I yawn but I heard you
through the wall sorry for making you
yawn all right the break is over let's
go back and I actually got through
everything in the live chat in that five
minutes so that rarely happens that's
perfect timing
all right so let's go back to here I am
going to take a drink and I got the G
fuel so hopefully this will keep me from
yawning let's see Abby now says your get
your grinding on your lunch keep up the
hard work
yeah I have been I've been working
through my lunch bag for a long long
time but there's a lot to do and
sometimes you get in the zone you just
you don't want to stop brian says chug
chug could you all hear me chugging that
I'm really sorry if you could I
I will try not to chug loudly next time
I'm sure that was gross okay so let's
yeah let's figure out what we knew these
check boxes all right I think I'm going
to take I think was Michaels suggestion
and let's do let's take these checkboxes
and we will let's move them back to
false let's move them back to false and
then we'll do this search term source I
this states just search type
mm uh let's just yeah let's split this
out just to make it a bit easier I'm
gonna call this you just keep it as
search type oops
equals in the wrong place so this is
gonna equal this state search type or
and then we're gonna need to put in our
string that has all the stuff so is it
still here can I just copy and paste it
Catholic faculty major it's a Catholic
department yeah this is it it's still
right here
okay
hopefully this will work actually it
might not work I'm just gonna try and
see it but if any of you know without me
trying it'll save a few seconds do will
it just grab this value since it's an
empty string or will it see the empty
string and go to the or we'll find out
in a second I guess sir save and then
down here we're just gonna put search
tight alright okay cool so eventually
this will end up being a giant string
but for now this kind of solves the
problem of the checkboxes and then the
other thing that we wanted to do was win
a checkbox is clicked we wanted to
search so fetch search term I think we
can call fetch search term so should we
do
are we not doing the debounce search we
don't get search results this debounce
search yeah let's call this D bounced
search now I don't want to pass percent
of value here d valences do we need a
value let me think about this search
term value so the state session value
here so we don't need to pass in a value
to debounce search right it doesn't even
do anything with that value
I don't not sure I don't even know why
I'm passing it okay so we're gonna do on
click of a checkbox which it's handle
change we're also gonna do this here D
bounce search okay feel a lot going on
there let's let's check it out and see
what happens so I'm just going to start
fresh and we're gonna try to do a search
right off the bat make sure that still
works okay great and I want to clear
that out and well I guess it'll search
automatically no matter what so now I
want to click faculty great we got a
search automatically and it's only
faculty wonderful now let's click
Department as well and there we go we
have Department and faculty wonderful
now let's click major and now majors are
there let's take away faculty let's take
away Department wonderful
all right great so that's working let's
just make sure like let's say we hit
enter or take one of these away so do a
search
are we you know I can't tell if we're
actually searching anymore
is it not letting me search again
okay searches are happening then all
right cool and it is major all right
excellent okay so those minor changes
have essentially solved all the issues
that we were having all right so let's
think what do we need now it's just some
kind of repetitive work is gonna be
involved with just getting every single
type making a checkbox for it we won't
need to change anything
the only would need to change in the
code is when we add a new checkbox we'll
just need to make sure that we add that
type to this string as well and it
should work the next thing that we need
to work on is sorting so we want or
reverse alphabetical order and then also
by date so newest or oldest and we're
gonna have to go yeah we'll go by the
word press date that's not gonna be
accurate for everything because right
we're migrating all this data and so a
lot of the data even though it was
created you know maybe sometimes years
ago it's gonna have a much newer date
the exception is in the news all the
news that I brought over they all I made
the dates in WordPress match the dates
that they had in the old system the
Ektron system so those dates will work
and I think that makes sense I don't
know if I did it for events but I don't
think we're gonna be displaying past
events anyway at least that was the the
last time I talked to my boss about it I
think there wasn't really a need for
that so I think that'll be fun
as the site keeps on being updated that
will actually be somewhat useful if
people are coming to the site and they
just want to know what's new they can
use that okay that makes sense now what
we'll need to do as well is for sorting
it would be wonderful if we could just
sort the results that we get
automatically but we may need to make an
API call and get items back based on
that sorting this is going to be
challenging that's going to be really
challenging
the reason it's challenging is maybe it
won't be I think we've done something
similar in in past projects so I'm gonna
have to look through some old code I
don't think I'm gonna do it right now on
the stream because I don't remember
exactly where it's at I don't want to
take up a lot of time with that but so
here's but here's what I'm thinking so
we're limited to getting 100 posts in a
search so let's say our search actually
matches 500 posts but we only get a
hundred if I only sort through the
hundred that we got then let's say we're
sorting by alphabetical order like I'm
I'm not gonna get all the posts
certainly or if by date I'm not gonna
get basically the point is like it's
gonna sort what's only there meaning the
hundred so even if in the other 400
there's something that should be at the
top of the list let's say it's
alphabetic order and there's a bunch of
things to start with a they're not going
to get there at the top of the list
because we don't have that data yet but
if I make an API call I mean it's you
got to make another call right and then
I sort the data on the WordPress side of
things and then send the sort of data so
I don't just get the first
hundred pose I get the first hundred
posts already sorted alphabetically so
maybe it might only be a through C but
there will be everything then whenever
we scroll down the user can either press
a button or will do the infinite scroll
and it can make the next API call and it
can ask for it we can tell it to skip
the first 100 and do the next call and
then we can just increment on top of
that to make you know more calls and
keep skipping until there's no more I
have some code for that in an old
project as well so I'm gonna have to
check that out it was done with jQuery
but the logic should still work but what
we can do to save API calls is do a
check and say like we can look at this
that we're getting back here so we keep
getting back you know this data and
displaying it in the console if we check
this out and look at the length of this
array and if the length of the array is
100 then we'll do another API call but
if the length is less than 100 then we
know we've gotten all the results
already and so instead of going an API
call we'll just do a normal sort will
you just do a dot sort on it and that
should save us a lot of time I mean I
buy a lot like it's probably still gonna
be less than a second but it's gonna
save traffic and it should just be a
faster experience does that make sense
I just did a lot of talking and not a
lot of coding so let me start to code
some of this out as much as I can
so let's do let's do a sort by date yeah
let's do a date
and all right
so sir by dates will be
yes actually there's gonna be
yeah let's make a new function and you
know I'm gonna get rid of this for now
and fresh filtered I'm gonna get rid of
this for now filter by category
let's leave this in for now okay so
let's say sort so we're gonna do sorts
and then we're gonna say type so the
sort type and then we'll go in here and
here's where we'll do our function
whoops yeah I don't think I can use sort
let's go sort if I can use that oh I
forgot my error there we go
so I guess we could do at first we're
just going to do one type but we will
have multiple types at some point let's
see so we're gonna we're gonna check to
see if we have the data so if if the
state data is equals 100 length length
the state data length equals 100 then
we're going to call
what was that debounce search yeah this
deboned search and we're also gonna do
the set States and we're gonna make
state it will be sort by oops
so we're going to change the value sort
by and here
and so if I will be a string they need
to do
by a second this should work right I do
that right
I think is it just mad because in all my
spaces what the heck should I
oh okay I named it type that's hot
sorry that's silly mistake okay since
they swear by tight
so whatever tight gets passed in that's
what the sort by is gonna be and
eventually the sort by will probably be
a drop down that'll have four options
alphabetical ascending alphabetical
descending date ascending date
descending so that'll get passed into
here it'll set the the type and then
we're gonna do a debounce search and we
will modify our search function here to
add something into our URL to change the
the sorting on the wordpress side of
things so oh yeah all right so now if
it's something different so if the
length is equal to 100 actually I need
to say or is equal to 100 or it's equal
to zero right because when we're going
to do this this sort type this actually
may not ever come into play but it's
better just to put the check in there
basically it would be like for some
reason if somebody hasn't made a search
yet so the data is nothing then we want
to make another call to get the data
okay all right I think that I think
that'll be okay there may be some
unnecessary calls like that but we can
fix it later but I think it's better to
do it like that else so else me this
would then mean that the length of the
data that we get back so the number of
posts that we get back is somewhere
between 1 and 99 if that's the case we
know we have all the data for that
particular search so when we do that
we're going to sort the actual data so
we're going to take the data this
state's data and then we're gonna do the
sort and cool so let's see look this is
awesome it gives us the documentation
for sort so we're gonna have this
working here folks this is great
okay so sort and what we have type yeah
this is definitely gonna change based on
the type so from now we'll just pick one
I guess and let's just copy this from
our other project to save some time so
let's go to get up it's a pretty sure we
did a sort just like this in this
project which page is this page
resources I'll make it bigger once we
get there they are and so where's get a
knock on the door hold on one second
all right sorry about that
that was the head of my department so
did not wanna keep her waiting and she
usually doesn't knock during the stream
she's just a very apologetic about
knocking during the stream okay let's
see where was functions this might this
might be the better the better way to do
it hmm so what's this price filter oh
I'm sorry I'm not looking for filters
I'm looking for sorting sorry about that
I thought I did have sorting do I not
have that here
I'll shoot well my time is up so
normally I'd probably take a little bit
extra time and figure this out but since
I'd like to be able to make it to lunch
with my coworkers I'm gonna I'm gonna
not do that so basically I I must be
mistaken we must not have done a sort in
this this project so apologies for that
but basically what we would do here then
is actually sort the data and then set
the state whatever we got back from this
we would then set the state with that so
this would be like cause sorted data
equals the state day with data equals
sorted data all right so it would be
something like this that said state
what's going on
oops not equal sorry there we are okay
so you see what would what would happen
let me know if you need me to explain
that and I can explain it a little bit
more but basically like we were saying
the the point of this is to not waste an
API call if we don't need to and instead
do it short like this which would be
much faster and you know especially we
want to cut down on the amount of
requests going directly back to
WordPress so they're gonna be layers of
caching but we're not going to be able
to cache search requests because they're
gonna be so specific so that's the one
place where I'm a little nervous about
the load and it could slow things down
so things anything we can do to cut down
on the amount of requests is going to be
good also just for users that maybe are
on a data plan
you know we don't we don't want to make
requests from you don't have to out of
respect for for the user you know for
their money so for both of those reasons
I think it's it's our responsibility to
try to keep the the request to a minimum
okay so let me save that and I want to
push this up to github so that you all
can check it out and it's available for
me in case I'm working on a different
computer so let's do get status see
everything's been in search so let's do
get add Doge add and then we will say
yarn cm yarn cm is something that we
have set up for this project normally
you would just do a git commit at this
point and then put your message in and
and that's how you do it but we have a
little extra formatting for this project
so we're going to say we've added a new
feature and this is going to be lets say
filters for for search results no
breaking changes all right so now it's
gonna run the test it's gonna run the
auto linting and auto formatting and it
looks like we're gonna pass so far so
good
the tests don't take very long but we
certainly don't have a hundred percent
test coverage right now so that's that's
why they don't take so long if anybody's
interested in writing tests you know
feel free to write some tests we have
and n tests and unit tests happening
right now so whatever you're interested
in let's see good push
or it in whoops get to the origin
alright so that date is now available in
the github repo and you check it out if
you like use it for whatever you want to
use it for it's totally open source and
and free I'm gonna go back to the live
chat and answer all the questions well
yeah unless unless you all start putting
in a million questions I may have to cut
it off but right now it looks like I'm
gonna be able to get through all the
questions that are left all right
I'll be enough says isn't it better to
use redux in this application um I I
don't know that we need redux really the
only place where I even thought Redux
would be helpful is maybe for this
search so if we do need some redox like
functionality it
Apolo now has some of that built in so
I'd have to look that up and see how to
use it but I do believe the newer
versions of Apollo have that so if I
think we need it at some point we'll do
that if there are some some good reasons
why you think we should use Redux please
let me know I'm definitely I'll
definitely consider it
Michael says I did something like this
and PHP slash my sequel pre github but I
don't know where it is well that's cool
if you uh if you find it or you have
some advice based on your experience you
know let me know I'd appreciate that
Michael says how are you gonna grab the
next results after the first 100 don't
know WordPress okay so the the WordPress
API will allow you to like offset your
search I actually think it's called
offset is what you put in the string so
like in the let's put this donor so in
our string at some point in our string
we would just say like let's say at the
end I would type something like offsets
equals 100 right so now it would skip
the first hundred results and give me
the next hundred results so if we did a
search that gave us five hundred results
we'd only get a hundred sent to us first
as we scroll down we could have it so
that if we get far enough if we get
close enough to the bottom of the page
it'll automatically send for the next
100 results and then instead of
replacing everything in data we would
just add on to it was already there for
the data so we would essentially be able
to show 200 results or more as we keep
scrolling down but we'd never we just
have to make multiple calls so the way
we would do this is you know potentially
we would make another function that
maybe like would be called like fetch
more posts or something I don't know
what I'd call it and then it would have
all of this the same except it would
have this addition of the offset and
then it would increment so if we've
called offset already then the next time
offset calls it's going to skip the skip
200 posts
and then 300 posts so you know I it
would it would look like that that's how
it would work I have done it with jQuery
on another project so I know it does
work I just have to make sure that I can
transport that logic here and have it
work with with state and with react a
noble self Noble and savage says boom
shacka lacka also us what's your
favorite color my favorite color is red
and what's the airspeed velocity of a
European swallow hmm I don't know that
one
that's that is from Monty Python and the
Holy Grail I think that's how it goes
that's what's the airspeed of a Leighton
swallow and then they say well you mean
to Europeans well or an African swallow
and then there's this long conversation
that happens it's been too long since
I've seen it to remember everything that
they said but I do remember a bit Blake
says as anyone coded on a Chromebook or
installed Ubuntu in one I have quote I
have coded on a Chromebook but I didn't
install a boon to instead I used what's
it called
kimly I forget the name oh cloud 9 so
cloud 9 it's it's like a remote
development environment so essentially
it is like in a boon to server that your
remoting into and they give you an IDE
so it I mean it looks a lot like Adam
and Visual Studio code you have your
terminal at the bottom so you can run
all your Linux commands install whatever
you need to and you know have all your
different projects I believe you can
pull in stuff from it it's synced up you
know with github and with different
things so it makes it a bit easier so I
have done that before
and if you're using cloud 9 it's it's
fine I mean it's it's actually really
easy to use I haven't installed Ubuntu
but I kind of want to I have a current
book right now and that the screen is
broken but I could still use
an HDMI cable and use like a desk so
would essentially be changing it into a
desktop computer because it would have
to have a static screen but I'm thinking
about since it's already broken just
trying to do Linux on there and if I
mess it up who cares
so we'll see I haven't decided for sure
what I want to do with that one yet Adam
so c9 requires the credit card though it
does now yeah when I started using it it
didn't and then they got bought out by
somebody and now they require credit
cards so if you have the credit card
you know c9 is great otherwise I think
they're all there are alternatives but I
haven't checked on alternatives for it's
probably been like two years since I
checked so I'm not really sure what's
out there right now okay Blake's
debating between a new Chromebook or a
used ThinkPad Blake's as it was it
pretty snappy and what were the specs
honestly Chromebooks are the fastest
things I've ever used fastest like by
far in terms of speed like speed of
startup and things like that like pcs
are down here you can't even see how far
down it's off the screen and then Max
and then Chromebooks the fastest like
you can't even open the screen like fast
enough to try to catch it on a black
screen it's just it's there it works
it's super fast you sacrifice some stuff
by for all the speed I don't know if
it's still that fast if you were to
install Ubuntu on it instead of Chrome
OS to tell you the truth I can't
remember what the specs are right now on
the Chromebook that I have so sorry
about that but I got it a while back so
I can't remember but yeah Chromebooks
are they're really nice for certain
things I wouldn't want to do it all up
on one primary so I'll say this I've
never had a high end Chromebook but if
you're gonna go with a high-end
Chromebook it's gonna get pricey from
the chrome books that I've use which are
kind of lower in I wouldn't want to
that'd be my primary development
environment I just kind of like to have
more of the freedom to do things so a
Chromebook with Ubuntu installed that
that might be perfect
I just haven't tried it personally so I
can't I can't really recommend it I mean
it it sounds like logically it should
work out and be awesome if you do it
please let me know because I definitely
want to see like how that turns out and
maybe do it myself
div yesh says hello I'm just learning
react and JavaScript to I get frustrated
as I need more practice with DES and
algorithm and JavaScript can you suggest
me something you can try out the unity
algorithm challenges and free code camp
and there's a free book that's on github
called you don't know J s read through
those that's that's really great for
kind of learning a lot of the basics of
JavaScript and so it's text and then it
also has some exercises so check that
out I mean you can't beat it as a free
resource it's it's really good let's see
I think it's time for me to go so I'm
gonna might not be able to get through
all of this hey JavaScript to share hey
how's it going hey javascript er says a
Chromebook with Linux installed is a
no-go done it before trust me no good
okay so had a bad experience with that I
wonder if it would depend on the specs
of the Chromebook I imagine it would it
seems to me like Linux may use more
resources than Chrome OS is meant to use
so you might need a more powerful
computer anyway I just got a message
that said they're leaving in just a few
minutes so I'm gonna have to have to end
the stream thank you all for watching I
should be back tomorrow
try to stream as much as I can this week
and get as much done as we can on this
site until tomorrow have a great